شكرًا لك
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
شكرًا
اليوم لقد لاحظنا جولة أخرى من
حملة التضليل من
مجلس الأمن من قبل
الوفود الغربية حيث أثاروا في
المجلس قضية الطائرات بدون طيار التي يُزعم أن
روسيا استخدمتها في
أوكرانيا هدفنا  الزملاء الغربيون
واضحون أنهم يحاولون ضرب هدفين في
وقت واحد
باختراع ذريعة مصطنعة
للضغط على روسيا
وإيران ، المزاعم خاطئة ،
فلماذا تعارض زيارة
المفتشين الدوليين للتحقق من
أنها ليست مخدرات إيرانية الصنع  لأنه
ليس لديهم تفويض للقيام بذلك ، لا
توجد لجنة عقوبات
للسماح لهم بمعرفة ما إذا كان لديهم
تفويض أم لا ، لا يمكننا السماح بالدخول أو الاتفاق
مع شخص ليس لديه تفويض
بالذهاب إلى هناك والقيام بأي نتائج.
هي المسؤولة تمامًا ،
فلماذا نفعل ذلك